hugh jackman is back that's right and
he's not playing Wolverine this time no
no no he's playing a guy named Keller
Keller's American has interesting facial
hair really rough tough confused a lot
of internal complexity a temper not
easily controlled yeah yeah a lot of
different than Wolverine prisoners
prisoners is a movie about Hugh Jackman
and Terrence Howard who one day their
children are kidnapped and Jake
Gyllenhaal detective Loki is assigned to
the case that's right detective Loki
just like the movie Thor you got a joke
well don't [ __ ] make it so I'm sure
someone else has already made that joke
[ __ ] anyway the premise sounds simple
doesn't it sounds like oh we've seen
this movie before guess what yeah
haven't prisoners is a unique experience
it's emotional it's thrilling them for
such a serious heavy film it's quite
entertaining actually let's start off
with the most talked-about thing-- from
this movie that of course being Hugh
Jackman you look at that sexy
[ __ ] huge balls that I'll put in
my mouth look despite what I said
earlier about this guy is incredible in
the film is the most complex performance
in the film he absolutely without a
doubt deserves an Oscar not for this
performance he takes a character that
could easily be one note and eventually
like unlikable bring such a level of
humanity to the performance at the level
of three-dimensional death he brings is
just so absorbing to watch I [ __ ]
loved him in this movie man Hugh Jackman
your big balls need to be bigger I don't
know what that means but [ __ ] it I use
that's a compliment in a way I mean
you'll identify with the character and
if you don't identify with the character
you at least get where this guy is
coming from you Jackman he basically
kidnaps paul dano or day no or whatever
dinosaur and he kidnaps him because Paul
Dano is accused of possibly kidnapping
Hugh Jackman's daughter so what does
Hugh Jackman do he decides to take the
law into his own hands he kidnapped
fought dado and says I'm gonna torture
this [ __ ] he confesses he'll
keep him prisoner
now I didn't ruin anything for you guys
that happens fairly early on in the
movie and when it does happen you think
you know how everything's gonna play out
but it really doesn't go the way you
imagined it to it doesn't become like
some torture porn movie doesn't become
some sheiks offing they managed to take
a very violent set up and turn it into
something very compelling to watch I
haven't been this engrossed in a film
since the last Gemma Hayes movie I saw
these guys another jenna haze's she's a
porn star that's right i masturbate to
her just like a bunch of millions of
other people bunch of us are just
jerking off to the same person yep we're
all cool this one was two and a half
hours long but trust me when I say this
it does not feel like two and a half
hours it's just that everything in this
film work so goddamn well pick a
category of filmmaking any category you
pick it is solid in that department the
catering service was brilliant on this
film Pinta rec team by denis villeneuve
luvu is perfect I'll never figure out
what this guy's name is I don't think
anybody knows how to pronounce this
guy's name he sort of has like a David
Fincher kind of David Lynch style going
on a little bit and the writing is
exquisite the pacing of the film is
awesome the tone established the themes
that are at play here the questions of
morality how far would you go to find
her yoga that's this one was really good
at doing it it makes you go how far
would I go if my daughter was kidnapped
I would go far I would do things
uncomfortable things things that should
never be done I just go around to be my
balls in people's mouths what would it
do I don't know but you know what it's a
unique strategy to my superhero name
Wolverine in the tea batter it's just
this film is this ability to make some
people go Hugh Jackman you're going too
far and other people gonna be like Hugh
Jackman you haven't gone far enough and
something will be like Hugh Jackman
you're right in the middle of going too
far and not fart the way the story
unfolds the twists the turns all of it
it's just so damn good this is damn good
mystery thriller and the investigation
story led by jake gyllenhaal brilliant
this guy [ __ ] awesome yep he's
joining a list that dick gonna be in
this mouth one day it's right talking a
lot about things me in my mouth usually
balls of her penis but the tuna together
you get a man mm-hmm silence without a
doubt this is the best Jake Gyllenhaal
performance I've ever
it's the first rule where I was
completely immersed in his character
he's a total badass all tatted up with a
cool haircut very few people can pull
off that haircut and he pulls off that
[ __ ] haircut by ticking that haircut
and you know the thing that happens in
cops in these movies where the job takes
takes a toll their emotions puts them
into a place of darkness this is done
with such an authenticity that it's more
believable in most movies I try to do it
then the answer deal with you Jack been
constantly getting on his ass value no
not finding his daughter in time did the
way the to play off each other is it's
just so damn good just this whole cast
Terrence Howard you know war machine he
was a war machine was he poor guy
remember he was like next time for them
next time Maria Bello great she's always
like some depressed whiny [ __ ] and she
does a great job doing that again she
was like a wife to somebody that's what
cermaria Bella is gonna deplane a wife
only I want to marry her though she's
she seemed like she'd be hard to put up
with any up Paul Dano is the main
suspect plane yet again another socially
awkward weird introvert and wonder if
he's easy to talk to in real life cuz
I'm like one hundred fifty percent of
the films that he's in he's not stop
that he's like it's like talking to a
wall despite the fact that I was like
there goes Paul Dano again playing ball
down I couldn't help but go Paul down I
was really good at playing Paul down I
have like very minimal complaints about
this film this actor who plays Hugh
Jackman's son he had some scenes
particularly one really like loses his
cool at Hugh Jackman where I was like
that is some bad acting right there oh
how uncomfortable to watch and the last
20 to 30 minutes of this film does have
some like cliche very like Hollywood
script e type of writing thrown
obscurities a word but in [ __ ] it its
work now the last thing I have to
mention to you guys the cinematography
absolutely beautiful to watch I would
totally have an orgasm to that
cinematography Roger Deakins did the
cinematography more like Roger Dickens
my butthole this is without a doubt one
of my favorite movies of the year let me
get straight to the point here oh and
all I gotta save prisoners got it super
right
alright guys check it out my review for
prisoners why don't you go ahead school
that comment box below and tell me who'd
you have sex with Hugh Jackman or Jake
Gyllenhaal it's going to go ahead and
follow me on twitter you can click the
link right here and if you want see more
in-depth review of prisoners going to
check out my show called reasons to see
that I do with my buddy Jerry and last
not least you want to get update every
time one of my reviews is up once you go
ahead and click on this button of my
dick to subscribe that's right click on
the subscribe button right here cuz this
this little Ryan he's been a prisoner
for too long anyone's out of the cell
he's lonely he is aching for some gaping